a mãe
sejam muito bem vindos estou muito feliz
de estar aqui com vocês e eu gostaria
que a gente pra começar fizesse um
exercício sim é um exercício muito fácil
e rápido a gente nem vai gastar um
minuto para fazer e nós vamos fazer
simplesmente vocês depois vão saber para
que serve então eu vou colocar chutar a
ti é uma bolinha schumacker um triângulo
e esse exercício só precisa que a gente
esteja com as coxas livres vocês podem
colocar a bolsa embaixo e as mãos também
pra bater palma
então quando a gente disse xu touch bate
palma schumacher que bate na coxa ok tá
fácil né
então vamos lá 78 chutar de schumacker
mas eu gostaria que vocês falassem
também tá então vamos lá chutar xishun
mar que se eu errar todo mundo erra
acontece a gente entra no processo do
outro muito bem decorar o que chutaria
bolinha schumacker é a coxa beleza então
a gente vai fazer um exercício assim a
gente só vai acompanhar aquilo ali né
simples o vamos fazer uma vez é só isso
eu vou fazer uma vez pra vocês verem tá
chutar de chutar trecho maracaju touch
to market
então vamos fazer junto
começamos depois do 8 778 e um de novo
vamos lá 78 chutar techo touch
schumacker luxo touch uma máquina de
filmar que schumacker chamar o patch
chutar atingiu marcas de um marca de
chutar de chuva
gilmar chutar atingiu marca de gilmak
ajuda de chuva
quem acertou tudo por favor levanta a
mão quem acertou metade e quem acertou
só comecei muito bem então tá bom
podemos tirar o meu nome é carmen o eu
sou filha de um pai espanhol di san
sebastiano uma mãe chinesa de xangai
o a minha formação e medicina
tradicional chinesa e buscando
aprofundamento eu fui estudar o budismo
taoísmo e muitas outras inspirações
todas ligadas à cura mas cura integral
mente emoções e corpo e nessa minha
trajetória busquem conhecimento em
diversos lugares rodei muito essa
bolinha
tive tantos países que eu nem sabia que
existiam tantos assim
e em todos todas as camadas dos
miseráveis dos pobres dados da classe
média os ricos os diplomatas usar stokr
atas
então eu e convive com gente de todas as
camadas de diversas culturas hábitos
crenças valores diferentes e o que eu
pude perceber que é comum a todas as
pessoas
nesse momento é um tipo específico de
sofrimento é uma mistura de medo com
ansiedade com insatisfação e sempre
buscando ganhar e ser e quero ser um
vencedor e eu quero ter não sei o quê
enfim ii e esse sofrimento vem da nossa
do nosso hábito de a nossa maneira de
pensar
desde a pré história onde evoluiu um
bocado nós construímos estradas carros
foguetes
bombas nucleares a a ciência tem
milhares de coisas fabulosas têm teorias
maravilhosa sair muito conhecimento mais
a nossa maneira de pensar não evoluiu e
o mundo mudou agora o mundo é
globalizado
então nós temos que nos atualizar e
pensar globalmente o que quer dizer isso
a gente tem uma visão mais ampliada da
realidade porque a gente ver fragmentos
né
a gente na verdade nem vi a gente
reconhece porque a gente usa muito pouco
da nossa capacidade e pra melhorar o
mundo eu só acredito nos jovens e claro
nos adultos que convivem com os jovens e
fazem esse trabalho porque é muito
importante que a gente ensine os jovens
e as crianças a pensar globalmente esse
termo global é muito usado pelo dalai
lama mas provocou tio como coach é o que
eles chamam de visão sistêmica você olha
a realidade como um sistema e você
conhecendo um sistema você sabe por onde
como é que ele funciona você conhece as
regras de funcionamento deles se
conhecem as regras que ele tem pra
sobreviver
e aí você pode atuar livremente ele de
acordo com as suas possibilidades os
seus desejos enfim o que eu noto que os
jovens vêm com potencial fabuloso eles
são muito criativos eles têm muita
energia mas eu os vejo muito perdidinhos
insatisfeitos confusos frustrados
anciosos um pouco viciadinho nas
marquinhos e tem nada contra tecnologia
ela é fabulosa mas parece que eles não
têm consciência de que não só eles na
verdade nem de que essas coisas esses
objetos todos criados são para nos
servir e não nós a eles
nós não podemos ser escravizados por
eles eles servem para nosso uso
e é o que tem de errado no pensamento
que não serve agora para nós o nosso
velho hábito de ficar no passado e no
futuro
o passado nosso passado é um arquivo de
conhecimentos da nossa vida das nossas
experiências e arquivos são para serem
consultados e pediu uma informação vai
ele e acha mas não é pra ficar passeando
no passado porque você fica pensando no
passado vem arrependimentos culpa suas
raivas saudade na melhor das hipóteses
enfim um monte de emoções que são
destrutivas as emoções adoecem nosso
corpo está bem claro pra gente pela
medicina chinesa e que entre as nossas
emoções som é o nosso condicionamento
que está no nosso cérebro mas a gente
continua repetindo as mesmas conexões
neurônios em que criam emoções
destrutivo porque é isso
se a gente fica no futuro ae o que vai
acontecer só vem ansiedade e medo é
batata
então é muito importante a gente
aprender a estar presente é o primeiro
passo para desenvolver o pensamento
global
como assim eu estou presente aqui nessa
hora sem dúvida vocês todos estão
mas quantas vezes você já não saíram e
voltaram olha ela aparece aquela minha
tia lá de misrata onde é é muito
convencional não a gente liga a crítica
ao julgamento e às vezes reclama nem
pedir mais crescer um pouquinho né
julgamento crítico em reclamação são
venenos criados por esse arquivo velho
que a gente tem de dividir o que servir
que agora não serve mais ea gente quando
pensa no futuro o critério que a gente
usa é ou não só que vão do passado que
já não serve mais
então eles não se dão conta do
potencial por isso tão frustrados agora
o que fazer porque a discussão
filosófica muito gostosa muito
interessante mas existem técnicas
existem escolas e tem cursos eu tenho é
que vários alunos estou muito contente
de ver vocês todos aqui que usam que
ampliaram seus conhecimentos que usam os
seus conhecimentos que aumentaram o seu
nível de energia e assim abrange e
aumentaram a sua percepção da realidade
quando você está presente você aumenta a
sua perceção percepção da realidade é
interessante que até o campo de visão
amplia dá pra notar nitidamente enfim
pensamento global que é você entra você
enxerga milhares de possibilidades e de
probabilidades então o julgamento entre
os juízes e mesmo assim eles não julgam
com critério pessoal eles olham de todos
os ângulos houve em todas as versões e
dão um veredito
a crítica é para os críticos a menos que
você seja consultado e de preferência
remunerado pela crítica não faça porque
não ajuda o que julga muito fica comendo
de ser julgado começa a ficar hipócrita
porque começa a fingir ser quem não é
porque aquilo que ele é quando ele vê no
outro ele falou isso é horrível e à
crítica sem solução eu me lembro que uma
vez a alemanha eu tinha engordado muito
encontrei com um amigo todo bonitão
ainda eu ea equipe presente do universo
e fui marketing ele olhou pra mim
nossa chorar e sim gordon muito
eu fiquei tão triste que eu digo que
comeu ap centena para sair daquela
tristeza ele a casa eu não sei eu não
tenho balança
fechecler roupas ram fotografias
ninguém quer te carregar no colo então
ajudou em que nada agora a reclamação é
o que mais baixa freqüência vibratória
da pessoa e ela reclama porque alguma
coisa não está boa então todas as 3 -
são criados pelo nosso hábito de ficar
no passado e no futuro e eles não são
reais
o passado é perfeito ele já foi o futuro
a deus pertence a gente não sabe você se
não está satisfeito com o seu presente
você pode planejar um futuro melhor pra
você e através da ação focada no
objetivo reparem a ação que é uma outra
coisa que eu vejo que os jovens estão
perdendo o fazer
eles são tão craques em apertar o
botãozinho ci&t que perderam gosto pela
leitura pelo e aprender tão um mar de de
entretenimento e moda
não no sentido de moda pra ficar
bonitinho não que ter é um texto assim
mas todo mundo faz mas meu filho não
fique tantas horas com isso não é
saudável mas todo mundo faz isso que eu
chamei erradamente de móveis mas enfim
eles precisam a aprender a pensar então
é muito importante que as pessoas pais
educadores mentores
todo mundo que trabalha com crianças e
jovens seja preparado para aprender a
olhar mais globalmente e ensine as
crianças e os jovens a fazerem isso
porque senão eles não conseguem realizar
nada é mais frustração
eles não têm foco a prioridade muda e o
foco é um dos maiores patrimônios que a
gente tem inclusive na realização
principalmente na realização e um foco é
uma coisa que pode ser treinada
então por que é tão importante o ficar
presente
vamos fazer essa brincadeirinha aqui
todos vocês presentes
imagina e tem uma moedinha você coloca a
moedinha no anos a imaginação em segura
moedinha faça isso a imaginariamente
mais fácil fisicamente segure a moedinha
agora aperte a moedinha estão sentindo
um trabalho muscular
agora impunha a moedinha com toda força
como se quisesse que ela saltasse pelo
cocuruto empurraram
isso te tira do passado e do futuro
aumenta sua percepção da realidade quem
é fabuloso isso você pode usar o tempo
inteiro ninguém vê pode ser dirigindo e
vai fortalecendo o períneo que é um
músculo que sempre foi a base de todos
os nossos órgãos internos aqui os vitais
principalmente então e pronto vocês
podem experimentar isso vai subir uma
ladeira ponha a moedinha e continua
subindo vocês vão ver como ela fica
muito mais leve o seu nível de energia
sobe bastante então vamos voltar para
aquele e nós encerramos com esse
exercício só que agora todo mundo
presente em não pensa filipe o segundo
aquele por favor
aí vamos lá então concentração foco 78
chutar de chutar de chuva ter chutado
atingiu marca de chá mate um mapa de uma
toxidade chutar schumacker de uma chutar
disse o marketing marketing marcas no
touch chuva tem sua marca de touch to
touch
quem errou daquela vez acertou agora e
essa viu ficar presente é bom pra
estudar é bom para um monte de coisa ea
gente tropeça do que não está presente a
gente esquece a
bolsa porque não está presente um é o
que eu tinha para compartilhar com vocês
em que tem muito mais coisa fiquem à
vontade para me procurar eu tô
disposição e enfim muito obrigado dure